did you know that hackers can steal your
data using crocodile Clips let's
replicate a well-known Cyber attack
called sniffing which aims to intercept
sensitive data in network traffic
first we take an ethernet cable and cut
off a section
we had an RJ45 connector to one side
on the other we add regular crocodile
Clips to the ends of each wire and we
end up with this contraption
now we've prepared an experiment using
this computer as our victim we connect
our device here and end up with a
classic man in the middle setup
scan for sensitive data we use a special
script and voila we've extracted the
password hash automatically sent by the
computer when connecting to the network
drive but there's no need to worry
nowadays this kind of attack is unlikely
if you want to learn more about sniffing
and the types of data that can be stolen
check out our video link in the comments